alors voyez les images de cette femme
vous vous demandez peut-être qui est
cette femme c'est sonia lévêque
elle se trouvait dans cette avalanche
hier qui a frappé le groupe de
randonneurs et la survécu à cette
tragédie et on la retrouve maintenant à
4 mandeau madame lévesque bonjour
bonjour vous sans doute avoir bien des
gens qui vont être contents de vous
entendez est de savoir que vous êtes en
bonne condition et je présume la
décrivez moi un peu ce que vous avez vu
hier est vécue hier on a été rapatrié
par hélicoptère et avant-hier c'était
c'était la journée de cauchemar qu'a eu
l'aval anges
ça s'est passé extrêmement vite
et puis en quelques secondes on était
percé on est trois personnes de notre
gros qui ont été entraînés par
l'avalanche et puis il a fallu se
protéger aussi pour ceux qui ont qui ont
pu être épargné par l'avalanche se
protéger on a tenté de d'aller voir si
on voyait nos amis qui ont été entraînés
par l'avalanche
notre guide est allé sur les lieux et
c'est après puis tenter de voir si on
voyait quelqu'un ou si on entendait mais
malheureusement il y avait une quantité
d'un jeu il y avait à peu près 20 mètres
de neige accumulés au banc de
l'avalanche alors il a fallu continuer
pour aller se mettre à l'abri puis vous
devez passer très vite l'ouémé décrivez
moi un peu parce que pour ceux qui sont
pas familiers avec la randonnée dans ce
coin du monde là est ce que vous marchez
les uns derrière les autres et ça vous
ça vous a frappé de côté quelques lundi
savez vous
une que vous espérez vous savez on n'a
pas eu beaucoup de existe n'est que de
petite avalanche avant avant la la la la
plus grande il y avait on entendait on
en voyait aussi mais c'était mineur
on est à peu près à 4000 mètres
d'altitude
le sentier très étroit et les montagnes
sont très abrupte on faisait attention
aux avalanches mais c'est l'oeuvre
vraiment pris qu avec la tuque le
manteau et tout ça on n'en attend pas
toujours les bruits et puis même
fraction de seconde le groupe de
personnes marchaient pas à deux pieds 10
ans on marchait un peu à notre rythme
aussi parce que c'est exigeant montagne
mais on était quand même très proche et
puis l'avalanche était tellement large
qu'on a presque tous été si par la
balance nous on s'est ramassée dans le
milieu l'avalanche mais par miracle il
ya eu cette portion la d'environ
qu'inspire le jeu s'appelle vépy cette
poésie peas et ça c'est passé vite mais
nous on a été emporté sur une dizaine de
mètres
on a été enseveli jusqu'à la taille et
puis ça s'est arrêté sur cette zone là
de 15 km et nos amis étaient en avant et
en arrière et malheureusement
l'avalanche continuer alors nous on a
juste espérer que ça s'arrête de de
traîner la neige sur nous il y avait de
la roche qui a déboulé et la roche des
boulettes aux danses étaient des grosses
boules de neige qui tombait de 2 suit
puis moment donné s'arrêter c
mais décrivent et moi parce que vous
êtes dans la neige jusqu'à la taille
quiconque a fait du ski dans la
poudreuse bombé sur dix qui est mais là
vous quel type d'équipement comment vous
on s'y prend pour pour sortir de la
neige qui d'ailleurs est être lourdes
ans parce qu'avec 20 quelques degrés le
ça devait céder difficile web est qu'un
cette journée là il devait faire moins 2
mais c'était de la neige très collante
très mouillante et ça partait de très
très haut c'était des grosses boules de
neige présente qui nous ont roulé dessus
oui c'est difficile de sortir de
justement j'en avais ce qu'elles ont
jusqu aux anges puis j'ai compris le jeu
qui a fallu que je sorte mes jambes je
suis pour un moment mon conjoint qui moi
on s'est extirpé de de la neige et puis
c'est un peu de neige folle c'est
vraiment de la pierre qui roulait sur
une distance de je sais pas combien de
centaines de mètres alors quand ça roule
ça hamas la neige et puis ça finit un
grand bal de neige le y en avait dit je
suis pauvre 12 12 pouces de diamètre six
pouces de diamètre canal dossier c'est
près l'os et danser et à ce moment là ça
doit te le silence le plus complet ça
votre presque inquiétant l'aide vient
comment comment vous échapper cette
région la paix la priorité était de
sortir de la zone d'avalanche et après
l'avalanche on avait
bonne heure et demie de marche pour se
rendre à une cabane à quillan on savait
qu'il y avait une cabane où on pouvait
se réfugier ça c'était la priorité ça
met à l'abri parce qu'on était mouillé
on était rigueur fier et après c'était
d'appeler les secours pour être évacués
parce que la neige va continuer à neiger
et après ça le lendemain il fait très
chaud alors la neige fond et ça
déclenche d'otages
donc on pouvait ni revenir sur nos pas
ni continue il fallait vraiment être
évacués et notre guide local parce que
notre guide québécoise était entraînée
par l'avalanche
notre guide local coût 5
c'est lui qui a téléphoné très tôt le
matin pour avoir un hélicoptère qui est
arrivé sur l'heure du midi puis ils nous
ont ramenés à 4 points de rendez vous
estivaux oui ils les secours ensuite son
sont arrivés par hélicoptère ou
autrement
ou est-ce attitude il parce que il faut
repérer les lieux de l'avalanche
même une fois qu'on a quitté les
montagnes ça se ressemble beaucoup
alors quand l'hélicoptère est arrivé
notre guide coussin est allé avec les
quotas est retourné sur les lieux pour
prendre des photos de l'avalanche parce
que là c'était frais en mémoire ou
est-ce que ça s'est produit
et parce qu'il ya des familles qui sont
dans la tente qu'on retrouve les corps
de leurs proches
il ya beaucoup de neige alors c'était
important de bien identifier les lieux
de son souvenir exactement 6 ou pour que
une fois que les secours vont arriver
qu'il cherche au bon endroit
on nous a dit qu'ils avaient des
des personnes spécialisées dans la
recherche de disparus et l'armée
népalaise qui était rendu à jamais qui
pend encore à quillan mais que les
secours s'organisent pour trouver les
corps ça c'est l'autre priorité une fois
que les gens ont été évacués faut
trouver l'été paru vous nous décrivez
tous avec tellement de détails et de
précision je suis curieux de savoir
quand ça s'est produit
est-ce que vous après est ce que vous
vous amusiez en plein contrôle de vos
moyens ce que vous avez eu peur avez
vous l'impression que vous étiez
pourtant pour mourir oui j'ai oui on
sait on s'est battus pour pour survivre
et on a été chanceux
je pense que tous les membres de groupes
si la personne qui voulait mourir ils
sont aussi battus pour bill mais nous on
a été chanceux
en plus de ça est doublement chanceux
car quand on est arrivé à la fameuse
cabane il y avait un groupe de quatre
groupe hollandais qui eux en raison de
la neige avait décidé de porc partir de
continuer leur itinéraire de rester une
journée plus à cette cabane là alors
quand on est arrivé nous on a été notre
deuxième chance ils nous ont prêté des
vêtements sont réchauffées ils ont donné
l'assaut pinzon
vraiment réconforter rassurés ils ont
pris fin nous sauf si ça a été très très
très apprécié de la part de ces
personnes là et puis hein mais c'est sûr
que on est encore ébranlés et madame les
accies je comprends bien c'est ça vous
allez attendre des nouvelles de gens que
vous connaissez l'action disparu ouais
ben nous on est on s'est dit qu'on
restait quelques jours à katmandou pour
pour faire reposer pour réfléchir et
puis il ya une personne de notre groupe
ici qui a perdu sa femme alors on reste
avec lui pour pour l'épauler puis en
nous on n'est pas pressé de partir non
plus alors on reste c'est puis on attend
un peu de voir que ce qui se passe et
comment s'organisent les secours mais je
pense que la priorité c'est vraiment
d'organiser les secours pour aller
récupérer l'été paru parce que la fonte
des neiges
aujourd'hui il ya un effet très chaud
alors il ya une rivière très en bas de
l'avalanche
il faudrait pas qu'elle est on veut
récupérer le corps ou plus et je pense
que c'est seul
l'important pour que les familles qui
ont perdu quelqu'un puisse au moins
complète et c'était un clin d'oeil en
effet de d'épaulé ce conflit g bâle a
même un qui est très tôt pour vous posez
peut-être cette question là mais souvent
quand on fait ce genre de voyage
d'expédition c'est un défi on veut se
prouver quelque chose
est-ce que après ce que vous avez vécu
est ce que vous aimeriez retourner
songez-vous finir ce voyage là
éventuellement pour quelques raisons que
ce soit mais on n'a pas pris de décision
c'est sûr que nous on avait prévu être
dans les montagnes jusqu'à la mi
novembre environ
je vous avoue que les montagnes
enneigées avec la neige fraîche simple
wissam équipe mais je sais pas on n'a
pas pris de décision mais peut-être
qu'on va mettre un frein pour les
montagnes enneigées mais pour toutes les
montagnes
écoutez madame les vins qu'on veux vous
remercier beaucoup beaucoup d'avoir pris
le temps de nous décrire ça et je ne
rappelle avec une précision puis vous
avez une mémoire là c'est fantastique
c'est un vin bio pour les journalistes
qui tentent de comprendre ce qui s'est
passé ce que ce qu'on a pu vivre là bas
à l'écouter on vous souhaite meilleur
décourager puis on va continuer à
prendre vous devez l'être merci beaucoup